ganz ungewöhnliche gebilde stehen seit
neuestem in berliner straßen herum
19 solcher park netz stellt die stadt
direkt auf sehr belebte straßen
begegnungszone nennt die kommune diese
dinge die auch noch richtig teuer sind
insgesamt satte 800 51.000 euro
viele berliner halten die idee für
völligen blödsinn da wir sollten sie
sich in diesen staub und dreck hinsetzen
und die schlechte luft atmen da sitzt
doch lieber heute als morgen weg und
zwar sofort
weil das ist eine zumutung für mich als
anwohner als gewerbetreibende als jemand
der hier die straße rauf und runter
läuft sonntags wenn das ist eine reine
verschwendung von steuergeld
die bergmannstraße in kreuzberg ist seit
jahrzehnten eine der beliebtesten
flaniermeilen der hauptstadt
doch seit ende vergangenen jahres stehen
an fast jeder ecke
diese gelben holz metallkonstruktionen
herum nachts ist hier oft remmidemmi und
die straßenreinigung muss die dinger
zweimal täglich saubermachen viele
anwohner und geschäftsinhaber sind nur
noch genervt
die größte sorge der anwohner dass wir
hier ohne klos ausgestattet eine
partymeile sind und hier hausflur
entsprechend aussehen werden es ist das
grauenhafte was ich hier gesehen habe
ich über ich denke das ist einfach hat
nichts mit der straße mehr zu tun weil
es einfach den charakter der straße
zerstört in der schönhauser allee ist
die situation noch skurriler
hier stehen die begegnungszonen direkt
an der vierspurigen bundesstraße 96 aber
die stadt berlin steht felsenfest zu
ihrem 851 1000 euro konzept schriftlich
heißt es es geht um mehr platz für
fußgänger und flaneure um mehr
fahrradabstellplätze aber auch mehr
verkehrssicherheit die parkplätze sind
ein angebot zum verweilen ein ort für
begegnungen in der nachbarschaft aber
aus der nachbarschaft will hier niemand
verweilen schon gar nicht direkt an der
durchgangsstraße straßenverkehr
steht alles im weg vollkommen hirnrissig
ich bin der meinung dass das überhaupt
nicht durchdacht war dass ich
irgendwelche leute profilieren wollten
ende des jahres werden die bürger
befragt ob die parkplätze in ihren
straßen stehen bleiben sollen oder
wieder entsorgt werden 110000 euro
kostet diese bürgerbeteiligung dann noch
mal zusätzlich